durante estos primeros 12 meses ha
logrado Boris cumplir con esa Promesa de
renovación política
no definitivamente no y lamentamos una
respuesta a esta naturaleza puesto de
que la propuesta programática del
presidente borich era el cambio
transformación pero también refundación
y hoy día tenemos un presidente que si
bien tiene la legitimidad del voto con
el cual fue electo es un gobierno de
minoría que no tiene ni la mayoría en el
legislativo ni tampoco una adecuada
sintonía al interior de gobierno lo cual
lleva a que haga un segundo cambio de
gabinete buscando mejorar la gestión
para poder mantener esta alza que
habíamos de ver es circunstancial por el
manejo que hizo los incendios hace
semanas atrás pero que no es solamente
se va a mantener en el futuro
a propósito del cambio de gabinete que
usted menciona es el segundo cambio
ministerial y este que hizo ayer está
integrado por personajes pertenecientes
a partidos de Centro izquierda cuál cree
que será el rumbo que tomará el
mandatario
por dos cosas uno en la forma en que él
maneje la propia capacidad de decisión
presidencial donde se mantiene su ciclo
duro que tiene la idea de la reputación
la gestión política en cambio está
entregada a los partidos con mayor
experiencia y mayor tradición que no son
los que lo apoyan a él pero que han
logrado una alianza político y electoral
me atrevería a decir que le va a llevar
a que vaya Estableciendo una hoja de
ruta que va a buscar la medianía pero
sin abandonar ni los objetivos de un
programa ni abandonar la necesidad de
gobernabilidad que necesita para ganar
las próximas elecciones
Cómo están hoy las expectativas de la
población chilena frente al gobierno de
borch Yo diría que hay cierto
desconcierto obviamente hay un voto duro
un apoyo duro de quienes lo le han dado
todo su respaldo electoral que no es no
es más de un veinte por ciento de la
población pero una gran cantidad de
población que tampoco está con la
derecha ni el centro de los Derechos
sino que quiere resultados y resultados
concretos en términos de mejores
condiciones de Seguridad Ciudadana donde
la violencia ha aumentado muchísimo
mejores expectativas económicas que
favorezcan el bolsillo y puedan luchar
contra la inflación y la incertidumbre
económica existente y sin lugar a dudas
una seguridad social que probablemente
donde está la agenda más fuerte
anunciada por el presidente